Man: Let's talk about
the spread operator. Those are
those three apathetic dots that
you'll often see in front of an
array or any iterable. What is
the spread operator? The spread
operator takes every single item
from an iterable. Now hold on.
What's an iterable? An
iterable is anything that you
can loop over with our for of
loop and that includes arrays,
includes strings, includes DOM
nodes, includes arguments object,
and includes our maps and sets
which we are going to learn.
What is that? We'll use strings
and arrays, because that's the
simplest. That's probably most
of the uses cases where you'll
actually use this. It's going
to take every single item from
an iterable, from array and
apply it to the containing
element or the containing array.
Where is that useful? Let's say
we've got this featured and the
specialty. I want to make a
third array called pizzas, just
combine them together. You might
think, OK, we're going to const
pizzas =, and how do you combine
them? You just take one, and
then you call .concat against it,
and you pass it the second one.
That will work. Let's see here.
Console log pizzas, and that
works. What if you wanted to put
vegetable pizza right in the
middle of that? How would do
that? Well, you'd have to say
let pizzas =, you would have to
make a new blank array. Then
say pizzas.concat = pizzas.
concat featured. You got pizzas.
push veg and then pizzas.concat
again specialty. You have to say
pizzas = you have to overwrite
the entire thing or we're using
let there. That just becomes a
big headache for having to
manage that. What you can do is,
you can take every single item
in the array and spread into a
new array. Let's take a quick
example with a string first. If
I have the string of Wes, what
is every item in a string? Every
item in a string is just each
character. What you can do is
you pop an array around it, and
that just gives you an array of
one thing. What if I wanted
every single item of that
iterable to be its own item of
the array? Inside of that dot,
dot, dot, that's going to spread
each item into the actual array.
I have W-E-S as the entire array
here. Similarly, what we can do
is, we can take these existing
arrays and spread the items,
like featured, and spread the
items of specialty into the new
pizzas array. We'll make that
back to const, because we're not
going to be overwriting it here.
Now, I should be able to have
these pizzas array, which has
absolutely every single element
in here. Similarly, I can just
also add veg in the middle of it.
It's not a problem because I'm
essentially just saying, add
every single item from here, add
vegetable, add every single item
from specialty and we should be
good. Let's take a look at what
pizzas is now. Then we see
vegetable being added right in
the middle. What's also nice
about that is that, if you even
want to copy an array, how did
you do that before? Let's say we
wanted to take a copy of these
pizzas. We'll say const Friday
pizzas =. If you just do pizzas,
what happens here? Let's take a
look. Pizzas, and the write a
pizzas is the same thing.
What if I wanted to change from
the first Friday pizza from deep-
dish to something like this,
Canada pie? Now Friday pizzas,
what does that look like? The
first one is Canada pie, we've
replaced deep-dish. Now,what is
pizzas? Shit, now we overwrote
the initial pizzas one. That's a
pain, because what we did there
is we didn't actually copy this
array. We just referenced the
pizzas array. Pizzas and Friday
pizzas, they are the exact same
thing. What you used to have to
be able to do is you just create
a blank array and then you would
concat the pizzas one right into
it. That would just take a
actual copy of the array rather
then reference it. That's weird
as well. What you can do is,
you just take a brand new array
and then you spread every single
item from pizzas into this fresh
new array. I should be able to
go here and look at my, let's
change it. Let's change Friday
pizzas and see where we are at.
Good, but if I say just pizzas,
deep-dish is still there. I
wasn't destructive to that
initial array. Again, a
spread will take every single
item from an iterable and apply
it into the new array. Let's
take a look at some more
examples as to when you would
actually want to use this.